it's not on track for drew brees to play
this weekend remember he was put on
injured reserve three weeks ago today
today's the day he's eligible to return
to practice once he returns to practice
a three-week window opens for him to
return to action
no reason to think he's coming back
today or tomorrow no reason to think
he's going to play on sunday against the
philadelphia eagle so it will be
taysom hill who's 3-0 as a starter the
new orleans saints now 8-0 with backup
quarterbacks over the last two seasons
and it'll be hill versus jalen hurts the
new starter in philly with carson wentz
on the bench
and there's no concern
with taysom hill on the field none
whatsoever they're as confident with
hill as they are with brees i've seen
people in the media beginning to suggest
and this may be sacrilegious
that hill should just continue to be the
starter for the rest of the season
regardless of whether or not brees is
healthy i'm not ready to go there but
there are some voices that are beginning
to make that noise and with each win and
with each impressive performance by
taysom hill shireen i think you're going
to hear more people start to sign on to
that concept
yeah mike a couple things first you know
you're the one that pointed out that
that you think they put him on injury
reserve today so he wouldn't push to
come back this week and it makes sense
they should feel confident against the
eagles right they they're going to win
that game unless they do something
stupid in that game with jalen hurts
making his first start and it wouldn't
matter if it's carson wentz or jalen
hurts the saints are favored they're
going to win this game should win this
game but guess what guess who they play
next week they play the chiefs next week
so i'm thinking they want drew brees to
get in a week of practice come back be
ready and perhaps put taysom hill back
in his rule and perhaps mike he's more
involved in the passing game now that
they know what he can do they've seen it
they evident they have evidence of it so
perhaps we see him taking actually more
snaps of the quarterback and throwing
more passes as a quarterback next week
against the chiefs if indeed drew brees
does come back and start
and to the extent that there is a
dramatic difference between the two
quarterbacks why not use them as much as
you can to force the opposing defense to
be ready for anything and everything and
it could get it could get a little
awkward there could be some palace
intrigue if drew brees believes he's
ready but the saints aren't ready to
activate him from into preserve or once
he's returned to practice to activate
him for game purposes and the one
reporter to watch in this regard and
look
there are some in this business who get
a little
uncomfortable when i do this but it's
never stopped me before it's not
stopping me now watch edward's twitter
feed because if edward is reporting that
drew brees is antsy or drew brees is
ready to come back or drew brees is
confused it's all coming from drew
if if ed warder reports it shereen you
don't have to agree or disagree with me
on this if you don't want to i don't
want to put you in a box please listen
to me folks okay thank you if eduardo
reports it it's coming from breeze so if
there's any potential
awkwardness between team and breeze and
ed werder reports on potential
awkwardness know this it's coming from
breeze so that'll be something to keep
an eye on too
if they don't instantly welcome brees
back to practice next week once they get
ready for the chief shireen
and you know what mike sean payton's
brilliant and he's brilliant in so many
ways i mean the saints are 8-0 without
drew brees starting quarterback over the
last two years 5-0 last year with teddy
bridgewater but he learned so much of
this stuff from bill parcells and we've
kind of traded you you talked to sean
and you talked to some other saints
players who talked about the cheese i
think it was taysom hill who told you
about the cheese baskets in the locker
room that's from bill parcells get in
the training room ice cold so players
don't want to be there that's bill
parcells and influence that parcells had
on on sean payton but another thing he's
great at mike is the intrigue of who's
going to start at quarterback i don't
know if there's anybody better in the
league at doing this than sean payton
than hiding who's going to be your
starting quarterback i mean we talked
about the eagles came out and announced
hey jalen hurt's going to be our
quarterback sean payton would never do
that and so the eagles frankly are
having to game plan for two completely
different quarterbacks if you look how
the saints have changed since taysom
hill's been in there they've averaged
200.7 rushing yards and 38.7 attempts
with hill at the quarterback with breeze
there it was 29.6 attempts at 120.8
yards completely different offense with
taysom hill so now you've had the eagles
spending all week having a game plan for
two quarterbacks it's it's brilliant
frankly and he's one of the only i guess
bill belichick is the other who can pull
this off but i've never seen anything
like it because people always talk
whoever it is because you know who's
taking those first team snaps players
talk but in the saints case in the
patriots case only two teams i know of
in the nfl nobody talks
we were trading text messages earlier
reminiscing about bill parcells and you
lived it you covered it i just remember
hearing about it from the people that i
know that when parcells became the coach
it was the training room
that was reduced to as cold as possible
so players wouldn't want to go there and
the players lounge basically became an
igloo
extra air conditioning units turn it all
the way down so it's so cold they don't
want to go in there and hang out just
brilliant and look they didn't win a
super bowl they didn't even get to an
nfc championship game under parcells but
they were pretty good because of the
parcels influence and now the saints ten
and two on the brink of another division
championship with or without drew brees
and again if they win in philly on
sunday
i expect more people to start cooking up
the hot take that hill should continue
to be the quarterback even when drew
brees is healthy and i'm
again i'm not saying i'm on board with
that but as they keep winning you're
going to hear that more and more
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports